us-backed Syrian forces battling Isis in
its strongholds say they are close to
victory they are now thought to be just
250 Isis fighters left in Raqqa the
extremist so-called capital for more
than three years battlefield defeats are
shrinking the territory under Isis
control Holly Williams made it inside
Raqqa now she's in northern Syria Holly
good morning good morning we spent two
days inside rocker with american-backed
Syrian militiamen they say they are just
days away from victory the drive to the
frontline in Raqqa is at breakneck speed
in a battered Humvee because Isis
snipers still look in this broken-down
city Isis fighters are holed up in what
used to be Rucker's main hospital they
spot movement and these us-backed
militiamen opened fire but fighting here
has been sporadic for days because they
don't want to destroy what's left of the
hospital and because Isis has human
shields in this skeleton of a city
it's thought 2,000 civilians are still
trapped Mike Hogan is from Phoenix
Arizona and worked as a waiter before he
volunteered to fight with the Syrian
militiamen he told us how one of his
comrades fell to Isis sniper through his
wrist and his chest he died he's been
spent two hours lying there trying to
stabilize him the ambulance that arrived
to take him out arrived 20 minutes after
after he killed over in a cab north of
Raqqa one squalid corner is reserved for
the wives of Isis fighters and their
children Muhammad Ramadan is just 13
version told us Isis trained him to use
weapons and exposed him to horror
they brought a man in a car and tied him
up for three hours he told us then they
cut off his head and put it on top of a
fence raka will be rebuilt and a stench
of death which we encountered all around
the city will disappear but the people
of raka will be haunted for a very long
time to come
Gayle thank you very much Holly Williams
reporting from northern Syria